[Music]
oh
this 63 year old lady she
got caught she got caught with
this like crazy scheme of shoplifting
tell me the detail please yeah so she's
a 63 year old resident of dallas
and she has been sent to federal prison
for 54 months followed by three years of
supervised release
she should have lived that long and she
agreed to pay
3.8 million dollars in restitution she
has that already
well i don't know she's gonna have to
work for her you gotta start a gofundme
a lot of license plates
internet merchandise yeah so she stole
no so so for 19 years she stole
merchandise from like big retailers or
whoever know
like i don't know where she's i can't
speak
where she stole merchandise from but the
point is she would shoplift from a lot
of places and then she would
sell them on the internet and then gain
like a crazy profit off of that she
would go on ebay
or she would just go like through other
like markets
and on the internet it was worth the
stuff 3.8
almost four how do you even steal
what is she stealing yeah from retailers
and then she
sold it and got the money back uh well
it's so ch
yeah she made a lot of money we don't
know exactly how much but
from it was between august of 2000
through april
2019. also like 20 years 19 years worth
of shoplifting
she would travel throughout the entire
united states
and then uh yeah like she would just
find buyers on ebay
and probably amazon like who knows just
internet sales
craigslist and then she would send it to
them via u.s
mail the fedex other
other methods does it say how she got
cut
um it doesn't i'm not sure exactly how
she got caught but they did mention that
she used
shoplifting tools to disable security
devices
and then would exit the store by placing
these shoplifted items in
in a large black bag that she carried
so yeah i just calculated you just did
the math
200 000 200 000 a year yeah so she had
to steal about 16
000 well 16.666 or whatever
so it's seventeen thousand dollars worth
of things per month to make about two
hundred thousand a year
for nineteen years yeah a really
exhausting
is not easy or a few amount of really
expensive
right that's true if it's retailers i'm
thinking
where is she going you know is it like
is it walmart that's a lot of
[ __ ] 16 000 [ __ ] at walmart every month
i doubt it maybe it was like maybe it
was like macy's
and she was still like name brand [ __ ]
that could be it yeah bags and things
all right right wait i'm sorry
physically shoplifting yes physically
shoplifted in a big selling it
on the internet and then all these
buyers would
would pay her through paypal and so
that's what they're saying that they
fire sent approximately 3.8 million
dollars
worth i need to know how she did it
because it's just just blowing my mind
well she must stop lifting tools
to disable the security devices but then
she would have been in black bags but
she must have
gone to so many different stores because
they start to recognize you after a
while
and then she just went on road trips and
just she must have gone around the
country
she went throughout the entire country
throughout the 19 years maybe she was
like
trying on really expensive clothes using
her tool to take the ink tags off
putting them in the bag and then walking
out of the fitting room he's walking and
you can hit like multiple stores a day i
mean you can just steal so many things a
day
true interesting especially see i
probably have stolen like ones in my
life retail wise and it was like this
owl necklace and had so much guilt about
it
but did you like it though they should
remind you each time like yes i stole it
but it looks so good on me
yeah i wore it once but i was like
who did it it was peer pressure
all your friends made you do it my
friends were stealing a lot back in the
day like i had friends who were like
just out here
i was with uh some girlfriends we after
school we went to the mall because our
high school was right across the street
from the mall
so we would go there all the time but
then these one particular group of
friends that i didn't really hang out
with them much but this one day i was
like okay fine let's go to the mall
then they ended up shoplifting a whole
bunch of [ __ ] from macy's and i didn't
take anything
um and the security the security guy
ended up stopping us as we were trying
to walk out of macy's and then they were
like excuse me you guys come on you're
coming
oh and then because they were taking
jewelry like right off the rack
damn and then um and then they were like
you come with us too and i'm like
i didn't take anything and i had like a
really small purse and then so they
checked my purse and like okay you can
leave but they got caught
and they got in big trouble well at that
age like you don't even need the stuff
you just do it because it's a thrill
it's a thrill like people just like
they shop live for no reason honestly
that's the thing that scared me from
ever shoplifting because i did shop
lift once before that and it was also at
that very same macy's and i actually
like i took a gucci no was it gucci yeah
i think it was gucci
the a wallet like [ __ ] like it was like
one of those like
big wallet the ones that kind of look
like you're sticking my seaweed
like those kind of wallets it's like a
dollar bill yeah
kind of like a clutch thingy and then uh
so i had that wallet for a long time but
i felt so guilty every time i used it
and then that wallet got stolen from me
at my grandpa's funeral
oh [ __ ] so so like i'm a family member
so is your grandpa teaching you a lesson
yeah were you like this is karma
and technically now your conscious is
clean because someone else stole it so
they can't
cross cancel and you just had a
confession here so right exactly i'll
confess this before here
all right yeah so now there's a warrant
out for your arrest
no i remember i don't know if you all
remember the san anita mall like og og
og was this big when there was like the
wooden play
area remember it was there was a store a
sticker store do you remember a sticker
store downstairs
it was uh downstairs like kind of near
where like body shop is now
you know body shop and like we're um
lady m like that that section right
there was a [ __ ] sticker store like a
sticker wonderland and i'm obsessed with
stickers like right when you go in
literally the walls just have rolls of
stickers and like little stuff
like toilet paper style yeah you just
get stuck and then and then
people die in there like it's yeah um
i remember stealing a little sheet
stealing a little sheet of sticker when
i was like in fifth grade
and i felt so guilty about it that like
i was like sweating every night
and then like the is going to come
bursting through the door we know you
took those damn stickers yes
you eat it you have no choice um i you
know blame it on my mom
and uh so i was sitting with my mom at
breakfast one day and i just like
decided to confess to her
so like i was so nervous that they were
gonna come get me how
much time had passed i think i'm was
probably maybe like three months
old damn you lived with that guilt for
three months oh maybe
a time time is weird looking back but
then she was just like
like three months it was like two days i
was like sweating
but anyway there was a sticker store it
was really cute um that's it
how did the confession go down okay she
was just like oh
okay don't do it again she's like don't
do it but i i'm just like naturally such
a like a goody goody to be honest like
in my at my core i'm very much a goody
goody
um so that kind of stuff always gives me
guilt so i just but yeah no my friends
who like stole back then like
this chick who like stole all the time
and i would be an accomplice like i
would be with her and i know
i know she was stealing while we were at
pacsun
like she would like give me birthday
presents that clearly had a hole in it
from the from the sensor uh removal
what's up good at removing that no i
just went with it
still your birthday present yeah yeah so
what do you want
i was uh leaving some like grocery store
or something this was years ago
and there was there's a dude he had some
like baggy sweats on and he was like
um and he the security guard stopped him
right at the thing because he i guess
the
noise the alarm had gone off or whatever
and um or maybe it didn't and the
secretary just stopping at the door
some of the scarier ones they have the
silent alarm oh yeah so you so you set
it off and then they don't even know but
then security comes and get you
yeesh so this dude he had his hand in
his pocket
his pants pockets security was like take
your hands in pockets the guy's like
why what what wow security's like take
your hands right
he's like what and you hear that you
hear a clink
like the bottle [ __ ] fell to the
ground what clingy
is like all right come on come with me
wait what was the bottle he was just
stealing alcohol oh alcohol
so inside his hands are inside his
pocket [ __ ] had his big ass pockets
honestly the alcohol struggle back then
though when we were underage like
we would i have to get people to [ __ ]
get [ __ ] for it it's harder now because
they have that thing on top of that
whereas before when we were kids it was
easy to go inside and grab them but yeah
something yeah they got like just have a
homeless man buy it yeah yeah i remember
what they're doing is dressing up as old
people with the mask and then getting
away with it oh yeah
take off videos i'm no i'm still getting
carded for
not even alcohol i don't even know gum
like candy
no they're asking if you if you lost
your mom and [ __ ]
no one time i where's your mommy uh at
the bank
i actually [ __ ] up once i was at
chipotle and i was trying to steal a
bottle of tabasco
because like the green one oh i know
you get me you get me are you stealing
because you don't really first of all
you can't really find the green one
anywhere and then two usually if i'm
eating there i'll just like splash a
little bit whatever
um so i i grab a whole bottle of tabasco
the green one and i put it in my bag but
it misses the bag and it just like
shatters everywhere
you were like two like ha damn
that's me i'm so i'm so obvious
but that's another time i try to steal
and never again you didn't
got they were just like no they were
just like what the [ __ ] and then i i
asked for a container
so i didn't have you ever accidentally
stolen from being absent-minded because
i did that a lot
like i'll be in the market i'm like oh
chocolate this is so cool
and i'll be like hey joe what and i put
it in my pocket
and i'll like we would leave and i'm
like oh i got chocolate this is tight
[ __ ] i didn't pay for it man no no
but i do ask for stuff though like
sometimes like
you just ask for stuff like sometimes i
go in the store and i'll see like a cool
neon sign on the wall or something
look can i have that and then somebody
give it to me one light sign
where do you go maybe not that fancy but
sometimes like if you just ask for [ __ ]
people will give it to you like
i'm also very huggable so people just
like look i get that like if you saw
like a turkey
like display at ralph's you're like can
i have that yeah that kind of thing
yes because that [ __ ] is all um seasonal
right right they're like what's the
locker when i used to work at foot
locker um they would have these like
[ __ ] huge like displays of like new
shoes that would come out that would
hang on the wall
and so they would never use it again so
i'd be like
my like to my manager like i can take
this home yeah yeah whatever they're
just gonna throw it away so i'll just
take it i'd have these [ __ ]
so i take it home and hang it on my wall
these [ __ ] huge shoes i have so much
useless crap in my room because of that
like i'm such a i love these little
knickknacks and like
fun useless things um wait you worked
that foot locker yeah
that's it when i was in high school
i worked at hollister oh who am i that
was my first job
my first job was hollister at the mall
and then um
you seem more like a pac sun girl than a
hollister girl
thank you that's awesome um i'll take
that um
hot topic girl on you know some days
uh hot topic is totally right
now it's not now it's like pusheen it's
like it's like completely when we were
little
and hot topic was scary yeah i remember
that it's like it smelled funny and
no you walk it dark too hot topic like
when you walked in it was like that
movie thirteen ghosts
you know the third skips before like
halloween stole their face
hello kitty and like n sync shirts yeah
it's like novelty
no honestly it's lit like i get a lot of
clothes journeys now i mean
kind of it evolved from like super
alternative store
to then kind of like like a novelty like
kind of like you know those pop funko
things yeah i was shopping at hot topic
for a while like i always used to get my
black jeans a hot topic and the
occasional like band shirt or funny
shirt the band shirts yeah
and then now i feel like they've really
leaned into the like
oh now it's just more like just like
preteen stuff
actually hot topic was what introduced
me to like get into like my
my dark emo like punker phase that i had
in like freshman year i think but i
remember hot topic being so cool i'm
like oh my god this is so scary
it's kind of like a um it's kind of like
testing to be goth
yeah or testing to be a punk just a
little bit it's the gateway
to well that's where they actually go to
go shop because that's like how
like hardcore i used to be i was wearing
like
rave pants like baggy rave pants like
jingle bells out there
and a whole bunch of chains and
something yeah and then i remember like
i was in sixth grade and this eighth
grader was like hey she's she has like
nice red pants
oh my god so my to my five four dudes
that need
skinny jeans hot topic really
hot topic is that [ __ ]
you